with more choices than ever trying to
choose what to watch can be exciting
and overwhelming at the same time if you
need help choosing which prestige drama
or quirky comedy to pick up next
we've collected the very best new
television options of the year
adapting one of stephen king's many
acclaimed works is pretty much
always a recipe for success whether it's
on the big or small screen
hbo's the outsider is no exception one
of king's most recent works
the novel was published in 2018 tells
the story of oklahoma detective ralph
anderson
who arrests terry maitland a respected
citizen who coaches little league for
the brutal assault and murder of an
eleven-year-old boy
though there's physical evidence tying
maitland to the crime
he still has an alibi and it's
anderson's responsibility to break
maitland
even as the town stirs itself into a
fervor in the background
starring ben mendelsohn and jason
bateman and boasting a stellar
supporting cast that includes julianne
nicholson
cynthia arrivo mayor winningham and bill
camp
the outsider was a surefire win thanks
to its excellent source material and
pitch perfect performances
and critics agreed the series earned
rave reviews particularly singling out a
revo for her
scene-stealing supporting turn there are
plenty of crime dramas on television
these days but the outsider
is a standout ever since her breakout
year in 2018
where she stole supporting scenes in
movies like ocean's 8 and crazy rich
asians
aquafina has become a huge hollywood
star though she recently won a claim for
her dramatic turn in 2019's the farewell
she's still primarily a comedic actor
which she displays to excellent effect
in comedy central's aquafina is nora
from queens
developed and written by aquafina
herself the show is based on the
actress's true life
her close relationship with her chinese
family and her struggles as she tries to
make it in new york city
critics loved nora from queens just as
much as they've loved aquafina's other
performances
despite tackling the familiar territory
of chronicling a 20-something woman's
struggles in new york
aquafina's performance and the show
itself both earned
overwhelming praise if you want to learn
more about her real past and
love a good coming of age story aquafina
is nora from queens
is definitely for you a netflix
adaptation of a harlan cobin novel the
stranger comes by way of the uk
packed with british actors to create yet
another great crime drama
the series stars richard armitage as
adam price who is married with two sons
his life is turned upside down one day
when a mysterious woman known
only as the stranger appears and tells
him a secret about his wife corinne
when corinne disappears during the
aftermath adam must track down his wife
while the stranger
continues moving about town to blackmail
and extort
anybody with a secret they'd rather keep
quiet
one more thing if i were you
my brandy and hicks only two boys thanks
to its excellent supporting cast and the
gripping mystery of the stranger who
reveals herself
more and more throughout eight episodes
the series earned raves from critics
who praised its careful plotting and
exciting tension
whether you're a fan of cobin's work or
new to his stories
the stranger is absolutely worth a watch
adapted from philip roth's famous and
acclaimed novel
the hbo miniseries the plot against
america envisions a frightening
alternate history that bears some
unsettling resemblance to the world we
live in today in this different reality
charles lindbergh the famous aviator who
closely aligned himself with fascist
efforts and the nazi movement during
world war
ii becomes president of the united
states and immediately targets the
american jewish population
as anti-semitism spreads across the
country one jewish family in newark must
navigate their new reality and try to
survive with an outstanding cast that
includes winona ryder
zoe kazan john turturro david crumholtz
and more
the plot against america earned raves
from critics for its handsomely realized
revisionism
though they did note that it can be a
difficult watch for some viewers due to
its undeniable relevance
in such a different time the plot
against america might be tough at times
but it's
also already earned its place as one of
the most important series
of the year ever since big little lies
took television by storm in 2017
viewers have clamored for similar
stories set in seemingly tranquil
wealthy suburban areas with drama
simmering just
underneath the surface little fires
everywhere a hulu original based on the
novel by celeste ing
fits that bill perfectly the two shows
even share a major cast member in common
as reese witherspoon heads up both
series
in little fires everywhere she plays
elena richardson a 1990s housewife
living in shaker heights ohio who finds
herself
at odds with mia warren played by carrie
washington who stirs up trouble among
the richardson family
and in the neighborhood despite the
inevitable comparisons to big little
lies
little fires everywhere is a standout in
its own right
its first season has had critics raving
particularly about witherspoon and
washington's performances
shaker heights might not seem like the
world's most exciting locale
but if little fires everywhere is to be
believed it's much more dramatic than
anyone ever imagined between the office
and the mindy project
mindy kaling has had an amazing career
on the small screen
and never have i ever is the latest
feather in her cap the
semi-autobiographical story of a young
first generation indian girl growing up
in california
never have i ever marks the debut of
star mate trey ramakrishnan who plays
davey a 15 year old with big dreams
who's about to start her sophomore year
of high school
from there she navigates life love and
loss
shortly before the series begins davey
loses her father
unexpectedly temporarily leaving her
without the use of her legs
mixing a romantic comedy about young
love and high school triss with a pitch
perfect coming of age story makes never
have i ever an
instant classic for audiences of all
ages for a number of reasons
as co-creator lang fisher said in an
interview with buzzfeed
the show is driven by a passion for
representation kaling would watch teen
shows and not see herself represented
driving her to want to offer that to
this generation
there's no question that keeling
achieved her goal and with another hit
under her belt this creator has cemented
herself as one of television's most
important
i voices you so much you're here to
cheer me up
unorthodox is adapted from deborah
feldman's 2012 memoir
unorthodox the scandalous rejection of
my hasidic roots
it tells the daring story of one girl's
escape from a restrictive conservative
community
and made waves when it premiered in
early 2020. the mini-series stars shira
hass as
este a 19 year old woman in the orthodox
jewish faith who is suffering through an
arranged marriage
after escaping williamsburg brooklyn
este makes her way to berlin to find her
long-lost mother
and establish a new life however her
husband comes looking for her
after he finds out some life-changing
news st
is pregnant upon its release critics and
audiences alike
loved unorthodox and widely praised
haas's central performance
though the story is extraordinarily
specific most viewers can relate to sd's
desire to live in a different world
making an orthodox a surprisingly
universal story
despite its tight focus based on the
popular novel of the same name by irish
writer sally rooney hulu's original
series normal people tells the story of
marianne sheridan
and connell waldron two teenagers whose
love story spans years
and social standings when the two meet
in secondary school on the coast of
ireland
popular student athlete connell
immediately connects with marianne
a shy bookish oddball and their
relationship intensifies away from the
judgmental eyes of their peers
however when they both go to trinity
college their roles reverse
and marianne's intelligence is prized
over connell's brawn
creating an imbalance hulu's series has
proven just as successful as rooney's
acclaimed novel earning raves from
critics for its slow
sensitive and thoughtful portrayal of a
young couple throughout the years
despite its often dark outlook on love
and relationships
normal people is a relatable gripping
story about young love
and emotional hurdles and with daisy
edgar jones and paul mescal delivering
excellent starring performances the
story becomes even more powerful
afterlife comedies are all the rage
these days and in the wake of the good
places finale
fans can turn to the amazon prime series
upload
set in 2033 the show follows nathan
brown
who dies young and is uploaded to a
pre-programmed
luxury heaven called lakeview by a
company called horizon
thanks to his wealthy girlfriend though
nathan is initially dismayed
and dissatisfied by the neighborhood he
eventually comes around
thanks to his assigned customer service
representative or
angel who is actually a living human
named nora who works for horizon
however as nathan and nora spend more
time together
they start developing unexpected
feelings for one another and nora starts
looking into nathan's untimely death
created by greg daniels of the office
and parks and recreation
uploads rye humor and excellent central
performances won over critics and
audiences alike and the show has already
been renewed for a second season
if you're looking for a replacement for
the good place upload will definitely
keep you entertained
well i'm not worried about scaring you
off now
talk later babe okay the premise of
zoe's extraordinary playlist
might sound pretty crazy but thanks to
grounding central performances and a big
heart
creator austin windberg's series pulls
things off perfectly
led by jane levia zoe the show tells the
story of a serious often stern computer
programmer in san francisco who
undergoes an mri
during an earthquake and emerges from
the machine with a surprising new power
after her brain scan zoe can suddenly
hear people singing when nobody else
can and quickly figures out that these
songs are their heart songs
meaning that they express the person's
innermost hopes desires
and feelings i'm just very very confused
you said that i was getting a glimpse
into other people's heads as zoe tries
to manage her new
ability with the help of her musically
talented friend and neighbor mo
she must also navigate a love triangle
between an attractive new co-worker
and her best friend as well as help care
for her ailing father who suffers from a
terminal illness that causes his body to
deteriorate
despite the objectively out there
premise zoe's extraordinary playlist
balances an imaginary power with very
real problems
perfectly and levy with her lived-in
performance and effortless charm
keeps the show from veering into
absurdity
new takes on familiar characters are a
dime a dozen but in their latest revival
of one of pop culture's most famous
lawyers
hbo has yet another critical darling on
their hands with perry mason
an origin story set in the 1930s this
new series casts matthew reese as perry
mason
just as he begins his career as a
defense lawyer still struggling with his
memories of world war one
and going through a divorce perry now in
los angeles
is brought onto a headline making case
concerning the kidnapping of a young
child
changing his life forever with backing
from hbo
and a cast that includes beloved stars
like tatiana maslany john lithgow
and shea wiggum there's no surprise that
critics fell in love during its
inaugural season
praising it as stylish and compelling
with an excellent cast
perry mason is a classic character and
with this new version of his story
and rhys in the lead new generations
will surely continue to discover his
stories
adapting a popular movie for television
isn't always the best idea
but in the spring of 2020 hulu proved
non-believers wrong with their new
version of high fidelity
20 years after the original film hit
theaters however
the new version comes with a twist john
cusack's rob
a record store owner looking for love in
all the wrong places
is replaced by zoe kravitz as a new
character
who's also named rob and owns a cool
record shop in brooklyn
okay so here's how not to plan a career
navigating her love life amidst several
x's kravitz's rob is rough around the
edges but
thanks in large part to kravitz's pitch
perfect performance as she speaks
directly to the camera
the show immediately succeeds in getting
you to root for her
critics almost universally adored this
new take on cusack's classic film based
on the original novel by nick hornby
kravitz's performance anchors the entire
show and she is more than up to the task
of putting forth the charming
vulnerable and powerful performance the
series needs
unfortunately hulu canceled the series
after its debut season
leaving fans with just 10 episodes of
this warm funny show
that said those 10 episodes are
absolutely worth a watch
historical dramas can easily become a
bit dry
and boring but in the case of hulu's the
great
facts matter a lot less than camp high
drama and glamour
developed by tony mcnamara who earned
fame and acclaim in 2018 for his
screenplay for the favorite
the great is relatively similar to
mcnamara's big screen venture
using modern language and other
anachronisms to boost the entertainment
value while still telling a somewhat
true story
this time mcnamara put his focus on
catherine the great in the years before
she became empress of
russia chronicling her difficult
marriage to the hapless lout peter iii
as catherine adjusts to her new life in
russia she begins to plot a coup
and it's hardly a spoiler alert to say
that as the series continues
she's increasingly sure to succeed upon
its release
critics agreed that the great was well
great
thanks to mcnamara's wicked sense of
humor and perfect performances from
elle fanning and nicholas holt in the
lead roles catherine the great has long
been regarded as one of russia's most
important leaders so it's fitting that
her modern adaptation
is so excellent based on michelle
mcnamara's acclaimed
book hbo struck gold with the innovative
i'll be gone in the dark which stands
alone as one of the most
personal and intimate true crime shows
in recent memory
mcnamara who tragically passed away at
the age of 46
in 2016 spent years hunting the true
identity of a serial killer known as the
golden state killer and the series takes
a creative approach to both her story
and the legend of the golden state
killer chronicling the journey required
for her
to write the book in the first place
with voiceovers from amy ryan
plenty of assistance from mcnamara's
bereft husband
comedian patton oswalt who provided
essential information
and a careful hand from its showrunners
i'll be gone in the dark
doesn't glorify the killer but looks at
the lives he impacted
critics loved the personal focus on
mcnamara's life and the golden state
killer's victims
ultimately mcnamara's efforts helped
catch the serial killer after her death
now i'll be gone in the dark is yet
another piece of her incredible legacy
anti-heroes are nothing new but
anti-heroines are becoming more common
and the difficult leading lady of mrs
america arrived on the small screen
at just the right time a joint effort
between hulu and
fx the 1970 set miniseries mrs america
tells the story of the battle over the
equal rights amendment
profiling both its champions and its
opponents the cast is peppered with some
serious heavyweight performers playing
real-life historical
and political figures with kate
blanchett as anti-feminist
phyllis schaffly rose byrne as gloria
steinem margot martindale as bella abzug
tracey allman
as betty ferdan and uzo aduba as
groundbreaking black female presidential
candidate shirley chisholm
mrs america shows both sides of the
debate over equal rights for women
casting shaftly in a particularly
unflattering light
with this powerhouse cast it's no
surprise that mrs america succeeded
right out of the gate with critics
loving the ensemble cast and the way
they brought to life the vast array of
different personalities in the series
chronicling this important period of
history is quite an undertaking but mrs
america pulls it off with distinction
we do not want housewives thinking that
we are against them we
are against them revolutions are messy
people get left behind michael jordan is
one of the world's most legendary
athletes but it took until
2020 for a definitive documentary series
about one of his biggest victories to
hit the small screen
an original netflix miniseries produced
with espn
the last dance tells the story of
jordan's final season with the chicago
bulls and their goal
to win their sixth nba title within
eight years
despite mounting pressure from the
entire world resting on jordan's
towering shoulders
combining archive footage with recent
interviews the last dance serves as a
comprehensive look at one of
basketball's greatest
seasons and critics lauded the series
saying that the show was a compelling
look at one of the greatest athletes of
all time and helped to further cement
jordan as a true living legend
even if you're not a sports fan you'll
still be fascinated by the last dance
you might know actor and creator
michaela cole from shows like black
mirror and chewing gum
but you've never seen her as raw
creative or exposed as she is in
hbo's i may destroy you throughout this
heartbreaking series
viewers follow coal as arabella a
millennial writer who wakes up
after a wild night out with a few
fleeting memories of being assaulted
initially arabella is on a simple
mission to find out what happened to her
but as the series evolves
so does the narrative creating a
complicated dark
and intense story of the realities of
assault and the culture surrounding it
the difficulties of social media and
what it means to seek revenge
are you okay
there is there is blood uh dripping
as the series continued cole was hailed
as the next great creative mind on
television and thanks to a devastatingly
perfect
ending i may destroy you has earned its
spot in the television hall of fame
critics flocked to praise the show
saying that it is both
brave and thoughtful utilizing stellar
writing
dark humor and cool's many talents to
tell a remarkable tale of trauma
and how we cope with it i may destroy
you might destroy you
but you won't regret spending time in
cole's world
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite series are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one